mais d'abord donc le cumul des mandats
ou non de l'ancrage territorial les
sénateurs sont donc revenus hier sur la
loi votée en 2014 sous françois hollande
aux rêves états pour l'adoption 197
contre 119 le sénat a adopté par ce vote
le sénat revient sur l'une des mesures
phares du quinquennat hollande la fin du
cumul des mandats depuis 2014 la loi
interdit strictement aux sénateurs
députés ou eurodéputés d'être élu maire
ou même adjoint au maire à l'époque les
débats sur ce texte avait été houleux au
sénat quel que soit le vote tu sauras le
vôtre ce texte sera adopté et avait
chamboulé le parlement 77% des sénateurs
et 88% des députés est exercée en 2014
au moins un autre mandat électif qu'ils
ont dû abandonner sept ans plus tard
hervé marseille estime que la mesure
était une fausse bonne idée les
parlementaires n'ont pas vu leur rôle
renforcé depuis l'entrée en vigueur de
ce non cumul oui les mères qui ne sont
plus parlementaires ont souvent bien
plus de mal à faire entendre leur voix
sa proposition de loi adoptée au sénat
sans le vote de la gauche permet aux
parlementaires français et européens
d'être également maire ou adjoint au
maire d'une municipalité de moins de
10000 habitants ce qui représente 97%
des communes dans l'hexagone d'après un
sondage 57% des français soutiendra la
mesure
hervé marseille souhaitait aussi
interdire le cumul des indemnités pour
éviter toute polémique mais cette partie
du texte jugé anticonstitutionnelle a
été supprimée en commission
il y avait une rupture d'égalité
notamment pour des parlementaires qui
ont déjà un mandat local comme
conseiller départemental conseil
régional et qui peuvent cumuler leur
indemnité le texte arrivera en novembre
à l'assemblée s'il a peu de chances de
voir le jour avant la fin du quinquennat
le sujet pourrait s'inviter dans la
campagne présidentielle
le renouvellement de la vie politique la
parité la rémunération des
parlementaires ya énormément de thèmes
qui sont passionnants et qui sont
associés à
cette loi à ce qui a été voté hier au
sénat retour ou non des cumulards voilà
comment on a titré ce débat j'accueille
sophie taille et polluant bonjour
bonjour
cette sénatrice écologiste du val de
marne stéphane le rudulier bonjour
bonsoir vous êtes sénateur l ère des
bouches du rhône rapporteur du texte a
été voté hier au sénat florent azy ho
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
enseignant à sciences po fondateur du
think tank les théories et vous venez
d'être nommé secrétaire national du ps
en charge de la transformation de
l'action publique on est en plein dans
le thème à matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste à mes côtés comme tous les
lundis mercredis bon soir mathieu merci
d'être là peut-être ont un petit retour
en arrière sur ce qui était la loi de
février 2014 c'est assez simple
interdiction du cumul de fonctions
exécutives locales avec le mandat de
député sénateur ou de député européen
stéphane le rudulier vous porter cette
cette loi qui a été votée ya aussi en
quoi est-ce qu'il fallait changer
d'après vous peut-être revenir en
arrière selon certains alors c'est pas
c'est pas complètement un retour en
arrière petite précision ça ne concerne
pas les parlementaires européens c'est
un autre texte là c'était un projet de
loi organique uniquement sur les mandats
nationaux pourquoi il fallait revenir
sur cette loi on s'est rendu compte que
contrairement à ce qu'avait été
argumenté en 2014 les parlementaires et
surtout les députés ont été totalement
déconnectée des réalités de terrain et
j'en veux pour preuve que quand on
regarde la qualité du travail législatif
de l'assemblée nationale on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya une détérioration depuis
maintenant quatre ans et que j'ai à dire
heureusement que le sénat qui comporte
dans sa genèse des élus qui ont eu
l'expérience d'un mandat de maire ou
président de département et rectifie les
dispositions législatives je prends
qu'un seul exemple la loi climat et
résilience il ya eu un amendement d'un
député qui est imposé aux communes de
mettre 100 % de leurs flottes véhicule à
l'électrique pour 2025 c'est une dépense
normative complexe qui n'était pas
soutenable au niveau des communes ce
député n'avait jamais exercé de mandat
local donc il ne pouvait pas comprendre
même si ça pouvait partir d'un bon
sentiment les contraintes qui pèsent sur
les collectifs à sophie taillé et poli
est ce que vous avez ce sentiment d'un
retour vers le futur on a beaucoup pour
ça se passe aujourd'hui non non c'est
retour va le vers le passé le très très
très très clairement je comprends la
remarque qui est fait par mon collègue
cela dit les difficultés aujourd'hui
rencontré à l'assemblée nationale deux
députés hors sol ne proviennent pas de
la loi de non cumul des mandats ils
proviennent de la façon dont le
président la république hors de toute
réalité politique locale et on l'a bien
vu malgré tous ses efforts il n'a pas
réussi à s'ancrer a fait une sorte de
grand job dating a demandé des cv de ci
de là à des gens qui se dit tiens
mathieu c'est peut-être sympa comme job
en fait de faire députés n'ayant jamais
effectivement eu d'expérience ni
politique ni syndicale ni associative
aucunement dans le dans la vie politique
ou dans la vie où je dirais
citoyenne tout simplement et donc
effectivement cette déconnexion que l'on
a observé tout au long de ce quinquennat
elle n'est pas lié je dirais à 7 à cette
interdiction de cumul qui pond à mon
sens c'est une bonne mesure elle est
liée à cette spécificité sorte
d'accident et c'est le président
lui-même qui disait qu'il était
président par effraction je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup d'écouté aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale qui ont été élus
dans ce sens est dans cette veine là et
que même s'ils ont représenté ce qui
était une bonne chose une forme de
renouvellement oui voilà
cherchez vous aussi était-ce le jeu il
n'y a pas de représentants de la
majorité pour vous répondre et mathieu
sarfati quai il ne suffit pas pour
défendre j'ai bien compris ce qu'eux
mais quand même je trouve que votre
discours peut laisser entendre qu'il
faudrait laisser la politique aux
professionnels la politique et parce que
voilà une forme de mépris pour ces gens
qui étaient parfois dentiste professeur
enfin qu'avait des professions issus de
la société civile et qui sont dit voilà
l'occasion de m'engager en politique son
histoire parce qu'on est antiste ou
professeurs parler forcément déconnectés
du terrain et pas besoin d'être élu
local pour être déconnectés du terrain
donc je trouve que c'est un peu un peu
bizarre par ailleurs il faut aussi dire
que dans ce groupe là il ya eu aussi
beaucoup d'anciens de différents partis
recyclé dans le micro ni donc c'est des
gens qui avaient une formation politique
est parfois exerçait un mot de réponse à
notre siège moi j'ai un engagement
politique depuis l'âge de 18 ans mais
cela dit j'ai travaillé dans ma vie
avant d'être élu parlementaire j'ai même
travaillé en étant élu local parce que
beaucoup d'élus locaux n'ont pas les
moyens de se dette des professionnels
donc voilà on une activité on
professionnelle et donc ne sont pas des
professionnels de la politique au sommet
ils ont quand même une implication
citoyenne c'est ça dont je parlais une
implication citoyenne antérieur et je
pense que finalement si on a vu cette
déconnexion ce n'est pas tant à cause du
cumul des mandats que de 7 c'est arrivé
je dirais un peu hors sol de l'élection
d' emmanuel macron après à l'assemblée
nationale il ya eu un renouvellement qui
était nécessaire parce qu'en fait si
dans cette période il ya eu ce moule ce
moment là c'était certainement parce
qu'ils avaient une sclérose mais je
pense pas du tout que c'était lié aux à
la halle à la problématique enfin aux
décisions prises pour lutter contre le
cumul des mandats alors on a dit aux est
un peu partagé sur ce qui a été voté
hier au sénat pourquoi oui pour cent il
y avait deux dysfonctionnements enfin en
tout cas on propose un dysfonctionnement
pour remplacer un ancien
dysfonctionnement c'est à dire
qu'auparavant effectivement l'absence de
le cumul des mandats bloquer leur
nouveau le renouvellement élitaire et on
avait certains élus qui très clairement
asphyxier la capacité pour des
générations entières d'occuper des
postes de quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
mais envoyer quand même une pour le coût
devrait et cumulards donc en terme de
fonctionnement démocratique de
renouvellement démocratique y avait un
vrai sujet et de ce point de vue là à
l'assemblée nationale la loi a répondu
un objectif au sénat c'est compliqué de
dire qu'il y avait ce problème là
puisque les sénateurs sont issus des
collectivités territoriales donc là nous
parle des connexions et j'ai noté que
monsieur le sénateur ne prenait que
l'assemblée nationale en exemple et là
on est en train de remplacer par un
autre dysfonctionnement c'est à dire
qu'on va réintroduire la capacité pour
un ancrage local et et moi ça m'étonne
un peu parce que effectivement je suis
partagé sur la question sert je
comprends pour les parlementaires parce
qu'on les voit ils ont été totalement
exclue d'un ancrage local je parle pas
de déconnexion c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment de l'ancrage local la kpc de
représentativité c'est dans les pures de
la démocratie représentative ans ne
représentent pas un territoire on
représente une fraction de la nation
sauf que les jeux politiques font qu' il
faut bien tirer sa légitimité de quelque
part et lorsqu'on ne m'attire pas du
terrain on la tire du président de la
république on attire
de l'élection d' emmanuel macron ce qui
a renforcé le présidentialisme des
institutions et donc j'estime que dans
le cas de cette majorité l'un le non
cumul des mandats à renforcer le
déséquilibre des institutions c'est qui
crée mon trouble été et je vais
compléter rappelez-vous la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 grandes
réformes plus de 50% des articles de la
constitution a été révisée
tout ça pour renforcer le rôle du
parlement et on s'aperçoit depuis deux
quinquennats qu'un affaiblissement
complet du parlement alors il n'y a pas
que le cumul des mandats j'en suis
d'accord on peut parler des ordonnances
la prolifération de redondance en dehors
de l'état d'urgence est aussi quelque
chose qui à fès nous nos institutions
mais quand même le cumul des mandats
quand vous avez regardé en 2017 lorsque
la loi est appliquée le choix des
députés maires pour la plupart ils ont
choisi choisi leur commune donc il ya eu
quand même une dévalorisation du rôle
oui du parlement c'est à dire que ça a
permis de renouveler le personnel
politique un peu d'histoire politique
mathieu quand françois hollande lance
cette réforme il le fait dans quel nom
quel contexte
ils ont croit pas un mot parce que j'ai
toujours été plutôt pour le cumul des
mandats françois hollande il le fait un
peu contraint et forcé parce que ça
faisait partie de ses engagements de
campagne
c'était pour monter un petit peu plus
loin à l'époque à l'engagement pris par
une de ses adversaires la première
socialiste martine aubry et qui avait
été recyclés dans le programme de
françois hollande donc lui n'était pas
pour manuel valls communiste n'était pas
forcément pour non plus lui qui avait
été député maire
d'evry une grande partie de deux pendant
son parcours politique donc ça a été
plutôt une concession faite à l'opinion
publique et à une partie de du ps qui en
faisait un choix politique plutôt qu'une
véritable volonté de la part du
président de la république de l'époque
françois hollande d'imposer son cumul du
coup c'est vrai qu'il ya pas eu tout ce
qui aurait pu aller au tour pour
accompagner notamment un renforcement du
rôle du parlement après moi j'ai quand
même une question parce que quand on
écoute hervé marseille donc du coup chi
chi chi chi des portais ce texte à
l'origine de ce texte je trouve qu'ils
utilisent l'argument curieux il i en
gros les maires ont perdu de leur
influence à partir mans ils ne sont plus
députés ce qui était vraiment de la
fonction de député on n'est pas débutée
pour avoir de l'affluence pour sa ville
donc et puis il dit cette problèmes de
déconnexion du terrain mais qu'est ce
qui empêche un député aujourd'hui
d'avoir une permanence dans ces quelques
circonscriptions a dit passer trois
jours par semaine à écouter les gens ont
conseillé sa satisfaction c'est assez
d'essence et municipales ou conseiller
départemental ou conseil régional ce qui
est une forme d' ancrage local est ce
qui a forcément besoin d'exercer des
fonctions exécutives pour avoir
l'ancrage sur étant personnellement pas
moi j'ai plus grand doute oui mais enfin
le rôle d'un conseiller municipal par
rapport à un maire est quand même assez
différent vous avez le travail d'un
conseil municipal c'est un travail
délibératif je rappelle aussi que par
rapport aux délégations qu'on peut
donner à un conseiller municipal quand
on est député ou sénateur c'est très
encadré par le code général des
collectivités territoriales que j'en
conviens m'en parler
vous êtes vous êtes confrontés aux
réalités c'est vous qui prenez des
décisions si c'est vous aussi qui voyait
les freins ou les aberrations peut-être
législatives c'est pas le conseiller
municipal
même s'il a une délégation il arrive en
conseil pour délibérer voilà son
principal rôle je ne dénigre pas des
conseillers municipaux
je suis un homme de nigré sidéré là qui
a pas de rôle d'un conseiller municipal
sans qu'il n'aurait pas de délégation
mais je crois qu'il peut y avoir un rôle
tout à fait important moi je suis
conseillère municipale visiblement comme
vous et je suis je dirais associé à sa
tante de de réflexion sans pour autant
avoir de pouvoirs exécutifs puisque
c'est bien le sujet c'est le faire en
sorte qu'il n'y a pas de pouvoir
exécutif mais il ya quand même une
capacité à participer au débat et
heureusement que les conseils municipaux
ne sont pas associés aux discussions que
dans le cas du conseil municipal sinon
il y aurait aucun intérêt à faire
peut-être que vous dans votre
municipalité c'est le cas mais dans des
municipalités où on pratique une
certaine forme de démocratie qui n'est
pas uniquement dans les instances
formelle eh bien on a des échanges qui
peuvent être extrêmement fructueux et
faire bénéficier de cette expérience
parlementaire mais je voudrais dire que
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que finalement
l'affaissement du parlement proche ray
de la remise en cause d'une incapacité
cumul des mandats moi je crois que celle
inverse je crois beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui accumulait ont
choisi la fonction exécutive c'est parce
que le parlement était croupion depuis
de longues années maintenant parce que
avec l'inversion du calendrier on voit
bien que tout ne procède plus que par
l'élection du président de la république
qu'il y a donc une capacité
parlementaire qui est extrêmement faible
affaibli et c'est la raison pour
laquelle beaucoup de gens ont choisi la
capacité d'agir c'est à dire l'exécutif
si on revenait aujourd'hui dans notre
pays une place qui serait la place
normal dans une démocratie
delà de la légitimité du parlement d'une
capacité d'intervenir et de beaucoup
plus de 2 de dialogue de co-construction
avec le pouvoir exécutif
je vous assure qu'il ya certainement
beaucoup de gens qui auraient choisi de
rester parlementaire donc après c'est un
choix qui les regarde
je réponds à plusieurs de vos
interventions je pense pas qu'on ait une
baisse de qualité de 2,2 appelé
l'investissement au parlement par
ça devait renforcer le présentéisme eux
des parlementaires
question alors qu'est ce qu'ils font en
2013 est-ce que vous avez vu est souvent
un renfort du présentéisme de des
parlements est-ce que vous avez vu ça
devient hyper prisa devait ça devait
améliorer c'était dans l'exposé des
moyens de 2013 la qualité du travail
législatif
on est en train de dire exactement
l'inversé comme quoi ce que vous
préférerez thériault nous
quentin calmer
de 7 ans soir quant à cette loi sur le
non-cumul a changé notamment en matière
de parité de renouvellement se poser
cette question sur le renouvellement des
visages depuis effectivement l'adoption
de cette loi ce qui est sûr en tout cas
c'est qu'effectivement avant le de cette
loi à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
il y avait une majorité de
parlementaires qui cumulait regarder ces
chiffres en 2014 effectivement que la 80
2 % de députées qui cumulent et 77% de
sénateurs alors ce taux n'est pas tombé
à zéro on le disait on l'évoquait avec
vos invités 1 la loi permet toujours de
cumuler avec un mandat non exécutif donc
par exemple un conseiller départemental
ou conseiller municipal il reste 5 5 %
des députés qui sont dans cette
situation 9 % chez les sénateurs en tout
cas cette loi permet effectivement un
renouvellement à l'assemblée nationale
en 2012 on comptait 230 nouveaux députés
424 en 2010 est beaucoup il ya beaucoup
de nouveaux députés qui arrive après
l'entrée en mesure de cette loi dernière
statistique on a voulu retenir c'est la
part de femmes dans les hémicycles alors
on sait que c'est pas seulement liée au
non cumul parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
lois sur la parité qui ont été votées
depuis et que le renouvellement de la
classe politique avec emmanuel macron ça
aussi affirmer une forme de féminisation
simplement on se dit que tous les élus
qui ont préféré leur mandat local on
peut faire de la place à des femmes en
tout cas ces chiffres il monte un on
passe d'un quart de femmes au sénat un
tiers puisque en plus le taux monte à 33
% en 2020 lors du dernier renouvellement
là on avait mis celui de 2010 est pour
pouvoir comparer avec ce qu'on pouvait
comparer à l'assemblée nationale où là
on est passé de 27 à 38 27% merci quand
un pur pour ce bilan pour pour ces
chiffres sur la question de la parité
est ce que vous craignez pas quand même
florent dady au jeu passe avec vous que
c'est que ce qui a été voté au sénat m
finalement un coup d'arrêt au
renouvellement est-ce qu'il ya ce risque
ça sera la conséquence mécanique par
mécanique vous dites ça arrivera
nécessairement parce que quand vous
regardez la sociologie politique dans un
territoire lorsque vous avez vous être
investis par votre parti lorsque vous
êtes désignée par votre parti ou par les
militants et bien c'est l'aboutissement
d'un travail sur le terrain de proximité
avec les militants et c'est donc lorsque
le cumul sera ouvert ce qu'ils ont déjà
une prime du fait des mandats exercés
qui pousseront leur avantage plus loin
parce qu'il n'y aura pas il y aura aucun
intérêt à ne pas être cumulards donc
mécaniquement cette mesure si elle était
votée par l'assemblée nationale
reviendrait à donner une prime aux
sortants et a cassé la possibilité de
renouvellement élitaire ce qui est un
vrai sujet parce que je crois d'ailleurs
c'est la mauvaise manière mais il ya
deux explications un certains évoquent
la déconnexion je pense pas du tout que
ce soit un sujet des connexions c'est
une question d'affaiblissement du
parlement il y avait d'autres mesures
législatives a voté pour permettre au
parlement sans révision
constitutionnelle d'avoir un rôle plus
important est de permettre aux
parlementaires de ne pas chercher un
refuge local donc vous dites fausse
bonne idée je le crois a désolé monsieur
sénateurs non mais c'est pas être désolé
par rapport à ce que vous dites
l'affaiblissement du parlement
force est de constater qu' on est obligé
de passer par la révision de la
constitution si on veut écouter
l'article 38 de la constitution sur les
ordonnances si vous ne retouche et pas
vous avez le conseil constitutionnel qui
en mi 2002 20 a été dans le contresens
du constituante 2008 en disant
maintenant toute ordonnance qui n'est
pas ratifiée mais qui a été déposé dans
l'une des deux chambres à force de louer
les mêmes pardon mais je jouerai rester
sur la parité oui est-ce que vous
assumer ce risque on est exclamé est-ce
que vous assumer ce risque que ça
s'arrête là non mais après c'est tout le
débat sur la compétence moi je moi
j'entends les maires aussi pardon c'est
à dire c'est à dire j'entends les maires
aussi comme vous dites qui se sont
investis localement et qu'ils veulent
après effectivement exercé des fonctions
au niveau national
donc à partir de là moi ça me plaît
faire ça me choque pas non après la
parité je pense que si les partis jouent
je sais bien eux qui investissent
pour les législatives
il ya des échanges via des amendes qui
sont payés par les parricides les airs
il faut voir un tout on vient le cumul
des mandats a vitrifié la politique
française quand même pendant quarante
ans plus tôt il avait vraiment rien on a
eu peur de nice on a eu une légère la
sueur dans la mémoire récente en tout
cas avant qu'on ait cette loi qui a été
votée faut se souvenir des situations
combat mais moi je cite souvent comme
exemple le rcd a très loin 1986 jean
lecanuet était sénateur député européen
maire de rouen et président du conseil
général des atours l'époque de seine
maritime c'était du grand n'importe quoi
on a connu des sénateurs maires de très
grandes villes
l'agenda mieux à droite ou à gauche qui
ont kiki cg qui n'avaient manifestement
soit pas le temps d'être palais du
luxembourg soit n'était pas toujours
dans leur ville ça a créé des notables
et comme la vie politique était quand
même très masculine on a créé des
notables blanc plutôt âgés qui ont entre
7 et des pauses pendant très longtemps
donc cette cette loi de 2014 avait quand
même permis de d'ouvrir les vannes de d2
d'ouvrir des postes et de faire monter
des gens qui n'y avaient pas accès au
bar vous avez noter quand même que on
aura pas d'enregistrement sur 2014 étant
donné qu'il ya eu déjà trois lois 85
2000 et 2014 donc le cas de leucan uemoa
et
pour montrer un port à peloter
associateurs d'où l'on vient l'envié
vient de la philosophie une organisation
centralisée de l'état fait que
effectivement on a toujours eu cette
philosophie de cumul pas toujours été
fort rompre avec tout puis de 70 bah oui
faut rompre dont je pense qu'il faut
rompre avec cette philosophie je pense
que le grand enjeu c'est vraiment de se
dire qu'il faut peut-être enfin qu'on va
peut-être d'ailleurs il faut partager
davantage le pouvoir voyez c'est tout
simple il faut partager davantage le
pouvoir pour faire en sorte que ce soit
plus facile aux uns aux autres d'accéder
aux responsabilités de monter en
compétences et pourquoi parce que ça
évite ainsi le fait que certains
s'accapare et géographiquement et dans
le temps avec un rapport à la décision
qui peut être parfois aussi vraiment
hors sol je crois quand on est dans le
cumul de plusieurs fonctions une ville
de 10000 habitants comme vous le
proposez puisque c'est quand même soumis
à dix mille habitants mais avec la façon
dont les choses sont organisées
aujourd'hui avec les moyens donnés aux
collectivités y compris en termes
d'administration de capacité à embaucher
des cadres de la haute fonction publique
territoriale qui est bien moindre pour
les villes de moins de 10000 habitants
je crois qu'on a d'autant plus besoin
d'élus très présent donc attention donc
à temps plein et qui ne soit pas et je
voudrais terminer et qu'il ne soit pas
d'eau s'ils font correctement leur
travail parlementaire au moins pour moi
ça me prend plus de temps mais au moins
le mardi le mercredi et le jeudi matin à
paris moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que par contres j'entends le fait que
aujourd'hui les maires des petites
villes n'ont pas assez de moyens et je
pense que c'est une refonte assez
importante du statut d'élu de l'élu
aujourd'hui les indemnités au maire
finalement diminue au fur et à mesure
que le nombre d'habitants diminue je
pense que ce n'est pas une bonne chose
parce que plus le nombre d'habitants
diminue plus les moyens de la commune
sont faibles donc moi il y a deux
services administratifs de capacité à
épauler les élus donc je pense que pour
un renouvellement démocratique locale
non seulement il faut partager le
pouvoir entre le législatif d'un côté
l'exécutif de l'autre ça permet voilà
davantage de gens qui peuvent participer
à l'élaboration des politiques et il
faut aussi bien sûr un vrai statut de
l'élu local c'est quand même aussi
beaucoup ce kimono ce pays je crois que
la toiture entièrement d'accord et puis
on a parlé de rémunération d'ailleurs
tout à leur mêlée mais sur le travail à
temps plein on peut entendre cet
argument qu'est ce que vous répondez à
lomé le cgct très clair là dessus ça
veut dire quoi laisser g7 le code
général des collectivités territoriales
comme le code du travail qu'est ce
qu'ils prévoient une quotité d'heure par
trimestre pour exercer le mandat local
donc c'est pas du temps plein et là je
vous rejoins attendez je vais jouer vous
rejoindre il peut pas le maire être
d'une petite commune être à temps plein
eu égard aux indemnités temps qui a pas
de statut languedoc il est obligé
d'avoir un métier à part et donc c'est
vrai que là il ya une contrariété c'est
de dire un maire qui veut s'investir
pleinement pour sa petite commune il
faut coc les indemnités fait une
proposition de loi pour un statut de
l'élu local là on l'aurait tous voter
après il faut être d'accord sur les
termes de la loi parce que dire on
échoue un statut d'élu local ça veut
dire quoi protecteur aussi se dire que
dans les halls des passerelles entre la
fonction élective et le monde
professionnel parce que on a mis en
parenthèse pendant six ans pendant 12
ans sa vie professionnelle toutes ces
questions doivent être payés mais ce
n'est pas l'objet de la loi organique
c'est une l'ordinaire sein mais vous
auriez peut-être pu écrire celle ci on
l'avait tous écoutez au lendemain si
vous voulez vous voulez intervenir oui
moi je trouve un peu surprenant de dire
que parce que il ya un problème de
rémunération des élus il faut les rendre
cumule 1 parce que ça leur fera un
complément de revenu avec l'objectif est
quoiqu'il ait suffisamment de revenus
pour qu'on puisse exercer une l'emploi
de maire à plein temps ou le fait de
pouvoir être connecté à la réalité
terrain moi je pense que c'est vraiment
le mauvais argument parce que il faut
effectivement comme le disait madame la
sénatrice revaloriser le rôle des élus
repenser d'ailleurs la dotation des
collectivités parce que ça a quand même
été la variable d'ajustement de l'état
des cas une un problème budgétaire mais
c'était pas le bon moyen que de leur
offrir un complément de revin parce que
deux choses différentes lavez statut
d'élu local vous l'avait annoncé on a
ouvert on a ouvert à moins de 10000 pour
qu'ils aient un complément de ces ce que
vous savez que votre démonstration
conduisait à comprendre que quand on est
à moins de 10000 habitants il ya des
enjeux de quotidienneté de proximité qui
sont extrêmement important parce que
c'est la vie quotidienne des gens et la
manière dont ils sont traités au niveau
local de 15 c'est aussi ça c'est vous
qui le dites et c'est aussi la manière
dont ils auraient ils conçoivent la
politique nationale donc quand vous
privez 1
maire de la capacité d'être sur le
terrain quatre à cinq jours par semaine
vous dégradez in fine et la politique
conduite au service des habitants et
vous contribuez à la désespérance des
gens dans leur système politique parce
que les cumulards ça reste une insulte
dans la bouche des leurs alors je sais
manger vous redonner la parole dans un
instant mais on va écouter une réaction
politique celle d'adrien cnas et c'est
sur cette thématique de
déconnexion plutôt de désaffection de
désamour des français pour la politique
c'est ce qui lui vient en premier quand
il réagit à cette mode de la loi par le
sénat moi je suis strictement opposée au
cumul des mandats et indépendamment de
la caisse même indemnité sens parce que
oui le glas évidemment c'est de faire en
sorte que les élus ne soient pas
déconnecté mais vous savez il ya une
manière d'être connecté je pense oui
tous les parlementaires aujourd'hui même
s'ils ne sont plus des élus locaux par
ailleurs ont à coeur de rencontrer les
citoyens de leurs circonscriptions
seraient pas de des élus déconnecté pour
autant donc j'entends ces petits
refrains mais pourquoi il va être
martichoux en garde et on a une
situation vous l'avez vu de désamour
pour la politique enfin réveillons-nous
80% d'abstention autant aux dernières
régionales à l'opinion n'en ce qu'il
nous faut d'abord lui donc ces
tripatouillages ce qu'il nous faut c'est
important c'est de permettre au peuple
qui visiblement ne consent plus à la
règle du jeu de la redéfinir c'est
pourquoi nous appelons de nos voeux la
convocation d'une assemblée constituante
d'aller y est passé à un revers de la
main c'est important pour passer la
sixième république alors ça l'argument
de la sixième république c'est un
argument de jean luc mélenchon depuis
longtemps à l'inca tenace qui était face
à elisabeth martichoux sur sur lci il
parle de tripatouillage
non c'est pas nouveau non mais je
voudrais juste répondre parce que ça me
suis dit il faut aller plus le fait il
dit il faut il tenir voiture il faut
aller plus loin soyons ambitieux faisons
une grande réforme quoi mais la réforme
sur le par rapport à l'affaiblissement
du parlement elle doit être posée ça
c'est clair je construis tout le monde
peut s'entendre ici autour de la table
pour dire que la place du parlement est
en train d'année en année de s'effondrer
par rapport à l'exécutif
il doit être on doit réviser l'article
38 sur les ordonnances plus plus calibré
des ordonnances par rapport à des
ordonnances dites techniques et par
rapport à des ordonnances dites
programme
deux notions dans la constitution et
puis également le rôle des institutions
et des juridictions parce que là aussi
il ya un sujet sur le conseil
constitionnel et le conseil d'état où je
pense qu'il faudra un moment donné
mettre en débat le poids du conseil
constitutionnel sur sur le travail
parlementaire est ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin
sophie calle polian sur sur le cumul des
mandats mais dans le temps c'est à dire
limiter le nombre de mandats qu'un élu
peut enchaîner oui je crois
effectivement que c'est une piste très
très importante et sérieuse à
investiguer parce que je considère qu'il
faut pas être non plus dans quelque
chose qui se fait trop court parce que
quand on est élu et qu'on débute faut
laisser le temps d'attendre vingt
d'apprendre qu'on n'est pas voilà après
il faut le temps de la pratique et mais
à un moment donné il faut aussi que ne
se constitue pas des sortes de baronnies
locales qui sont indéboulonnables et
qu'il faut apprendre que les élus
apprennent à travailler la suite après
je considère que l'ensemble de ces
modifications institutionnelles qui
doivent arriver parce que on le voit nos
institutions quand même globalement son
sont à bout de souffle dans la façon
dont elle fonctionne on voit le taux
d'abstention extrêmement important on
voit finalement ce mouvement de
recentralisation de faire tu de
capacités des collectivités on voit
beaucoup de choses qui dans notre dans
nos institutions sont à bout de souffle
et si nous devons tout repensé et je
crois que c'est le cas il faut le faire
avec les citoyens et citoyennes et
demande à ses trois mandats c'est quoi
le
écoutez un moment donné d'ailleurs au il
me semble je n'étais pas parlementaire à
l'époque mais en tant que citoyenne je
suivais tout cela est donc il me semble
qu'il a été posé un moment donné la
question de s'arrêter dans le temps à
trois mandats voilà donc c'est peut-être
quelque chose qu'il faut poser mais
encore une fois je crois que tous ces
débats doivent avoir lieu dans dans un
lien particulier et important avec les
citoyens et citoyennes parce que ce
serait pas la peine qu'on fasse ça en
chambre dans notre coin si on ne suscite
pas une nouvelle adhésion réadhésions
finalement aux institutions
républicaines renouveler florent radio
limiter le nombre de mandats d'année luc
hees faisant penser à titre personnel j
très opposées pour deux raisons la
première c'est que c'est quand même une
entaille supplémentaire à la volonté
générale parce que il le risque de
distorsion du suffrage universel il est
très fort dans le cumul des mandats
parce que les parties peuvent en quelque
sorte restreindre le choix des électeurs
la limitation du des mandats dans le
temps l'électeur peut parfaitement
décidé de sanctionner un élu qui est la
trop longtemps qui fait pas son travail
et c'est donc pour moi ya pas un risque
que les parties biaise aussi lourdement
le suffrage universel et le deuxième
élément c'est surtout on le voit il peut
y avoir des parlementaires qui effectué
deux mandats dans l'opposition et qui ne
sont pas élus et donc dans ce cas là que
se passe-t-il en fait on se prive de
compétence acquise il ya tout un travail
aussi valoriser le rôle du parlement
c'est aussi accepter l'expérience des
parlementaires et cette expérience elle
peut prendre un deux trois mandats donc
je pense qu'il faut pas chercher un
chiffre une martingale pour savoir
combien de mandat il faut il faut
vraiment laissé la capacité des
électeurs de sanctionner la trop grande
durée je crois que ça suffira donc vous
dis à tes risques de distorsion
démocratique en quelques cents pour moi
ça contribue à être effectivement comme
quand les gens quand nous nous
présentons devant devant les électeurs
nous
nous représentons aussi parfois de moins
en moins souvent mais parfois quand même
une famille politique est aussi un
programme moi je suis contre voyez le
présidentialisme et l'identification à
outrance et je crois que personne n'est
irremplaçable et qu' il ya des projets
qui sont portés et qui sont collectifs
forcément et s'ils ne le sont pas assez
bien qu'il ya une déconnexion
démocratique donc je considère que il
est toujours possible aussi de se dire
je vais passer la main parce que ça va
faire un nouveau souffle parce que ça va
permettre de renouveler un peu la façon
dont on voit les choses et ça c'est
positif ça c'est bénéfique donc
effectivement pas trop tôt parce que
sinon on n'est pas là pour pour empêcher
aussi la la maturité la capacité
d'intervenir et des lags l'acquisition
de compétences au fur et à mesure et de
compréhension et appropriation des
enjeux mais faut pas non plus laisser
perdurer des choses où finalement on est
trop là dans la personnification je
crois aussi que dans nos institutions il
faut qu'on sache en sortir cette
dubitatif oui totalement moi je suis la
vie là je rejoins mon collègue de gauche
a laissé le choix aux électeurs de
savoir si oui ou non la personne
le cumul dans le temps et se présente un
suffrage universel pour plusieurs
raisons parce que sinon effectivement
on va s'arrêter quand 2 3 on va se dire
il faut aligner par rapport au président
de la république puisque le président la
république c'est le seul mandat où
effectivement on a limité dans le temps
l'exercice du pouvoir donc voyez c'est
des questions après c'est comme les
effets seul
dix mines pourquoi 10000 le débat eu
lieu pourquoi pas 15 mille pourquoi pas
un mille donc c'est pas naturel et ça
risque à mon sens de freiner et de
rendre encore plus une situation de
défiance par rapport au politique le
fait que justement il peut y avoir une
certaine frustration chez les électeurs
diamal mon député ne peut plus se
représenter parce que ça fait déjà deux
mandats et malheureusement je l'aimé
bien c'est tout bêtement les députés que
les maires et des mères qui sont en
poste depuis 45 ans
mais si cécile ont été élus c'est
beaucoup et au demeurant il ya un effet
de rebond possible c'est à dire qu'au
bout de deux mandats le député devient
sénateur et puis ils reviendront
tout ça laisse lieu à je trouve pour le
foie de veau et tripatouillages possible
l'utilisation de là
ils en pensent quoi les les habitants
est ce que vous pensez qu'un habitant
d'une ville de diminuer de 10 mille
voilà il préfère que son maire soit à
100% et s'occupe de sa commune alors
qu'il devienne député je pense yens
certes viage de la colonie au parlement
juste question
les habitants une certaine fierté que
leur mère soit député ou sénateur
c'était vrai canton il y avait le cumul
ou un bon maire c'est un monsieur le
député monsieur le sénateur il y avait
certes fierté là donc je suis pas sûr et
certain que forcément ils vont ils vont
prendre le prisme en disant où là il va
être moins présent sur la commune il va
- gérer la vie ne sais qu'il ya des
adjoints vous l'avez dit vous-même ce
n'est pas la même c'est pas la même
expérience de terrain par contre je
pense que les lévites juifs wade lévy du
foie comme je suis élu de villejuif
milieu du val de marne ils sont contents
que je sois conseil municipal tout cas
ceux qui ont voté pour notre notre liste
mais par contre c'est vrai que j'avais
beaucoup de questions alors je leur dis
bah rassurez-vous la loi est là je ne
peux pas cumuler mais quand même et
c'est vous avez le temps vous faire
beaucoup de choses au sénat geithner ne
vous inquiétez pas
7 cette sensibilité politique ce que ce
que je peux apporter sur le fond je la
porterai
ma copine mais oui mais ils peuvent
aussi vous faire passer des des demandes
d
voilà des des réclamations gelé 30 si
vous en avez la courroie de transmission
au sénat aussi ça peut être salis de la
demande je les transmets à mes collègues
qui sont dans l'exécutif et quand il ya
une partie législative mais je peux
travailler un amendement que c'était et
c'est un travail je crois très
complémentaires et je pense que
d'ailleurs je ne fais pas que dans la
commune où je suis élue mais bien
entendu dans les communes diverses de
mon département je voudrais qu'on parle
d'argent vous l'avais un peu évoquée
mais dans ce que je vous écoute et de
soleure je me disais ça veut dire quoi
se dire que les parlementaires sont mal
payés insuffisamment payés est ce que
l'opinion est ce que l'opinion française
pas entendre ça sommes pas du tout fait
ce n'était pas le sujet je vais en
parler des moeurs bien donner un petit
coup un papa et les indemnités
parlementaires on n'a jamais romillons
que ça ce qui a été abrogée par rapport
au projet de loi puis l'avait l'article
2 effectivement le message que voulait
envoyer le président marseille c'est
bien mais c'est pas une question
d'argent et de cumuler des indemnités
celui qui serait maire d'une commune de
moins de 10000 habitants et députés
n'auraient pas l'indemnité de maire
d'une commune de moins de 10000
habitants bon le souci c'est qu'elle est
le risque inconstitutionnelle par
rapport à une situation que certains
connaissent d'entre nous qui cumule déjà
entre conseiller départemental conseil
régional ou députés sénateurs donc vous
voyez il ya la règle de l'écrêtement de
1992 bon elle s'applique à tous même aux
niveaux du cumul
horizontale parce que ça on n'en parle
pas beaucoup mais il ya des mères qui
sont également de conseiller régional
vice président d'une communauté de
communes une interco voilà donc cette
règle sur les traitements je pense que
c'est cette ligne là qu'il fallait tenir
pour éviter la rupture d'égalité je
pense que la question d'argent et
concerne moins les rémunérations que les
moyens ils sont accordées aux députés et
de ce point de vue là c'est vrai qu'un
député français quand on compare des
députés qui peuvent être trop souvent
l'exemple des états unis mais là c'est
clairement un océan qui les séparent
mais c'est une toute petite tpe en
france un député il y voir un assistant
parlementaire et aux deux collaborateurs
et aux etats unis c'est une gross ps zh
et qu'ils ont une dizaine voire une
quinzaine de deux staffs et à quoi ça
sert les textes sont de plus en plus
techniques les problématiques sont le
plus compliqué et un député tout même de
bonnes ventes et pas forcément au
courant de tout il a besoin d'un staff
pour l'aider à se documenter l'étranger
sur les îles et c'est ça qui en france ô
ma vie pour ce problème cela pose de
vraies questions florent radio sur la
capacité d'un député aussi à interagir
notamment avec avec des lobbys bien su
aussi pour ça que parfois des textes ils
sont on a un peu l'impression qu'ils ont
été pré écrit vous arrive tout fait
évidemment est historiquement
l'accroissement de la rémunération des
parlementaires notamment après scandale
de panama par exemple c'était pour les
soustraire à toute influence du monde de
l'argent donc on peut effectivement
réfléchir aux moyens
peut-être pas sur la somme est peut-être
sur certaines professions ne peuvent pas
se permettre des pertes de revenus aussi
importante parce qu'il ya ça aussi donc
c'est peut-être en fonction du salaire
qui est perdue qui a peut-être une
réflexion mais elle n'est pas
prioritaire effectivement ce qui compte
c'est les moyens des parlementaires et
c'est ce que j'ai tout à l'heure c'était
la plus mauvaise loi par laquelle
commencé parce qu'on pouvait commencer
par revaloriser le nombre de
collaborateurs qui sont à la disposition
des parlementaires on pouvait réfléchir
a par exemple limiter le nombre
d'amendements déposés par le
gouvernement en séance et qui n'auraient
pas été présentées en commission dire
qu'on pouvait mots de moduler les
pratiques politiques pour justement
permettre une revalorisation du rôle du
parlementaire une revalorisation du
travail législatif les moyens mais aussi
les pratiques politiques pour terminer
sophie taillé et poli est ce que vous
craignez qu'il avait avec finalement le
cette évolution si elle allait au bout
il ya une sorte appauvrissement des
idées idées nouvelles aussi parce que
quand on parle de renouvellement ce pas
seulement le personnel ses idées qui
sont portées par les nouveaux députés où
le nouveau sénateur oui non mais très
très clairement je pense que c'est un
appauvrissement et un rétrécissement là
qui est proposée alors qu'on a besoin d'
enrichissement et d'élargissement de
mieux partager le pouvoir de mieux
travailler aussi en coopération entre
les différents pouvoirs
exécutif et législatif est donc pour moi
effectivement ça ne va ça ne va pas du
tout dans le bon sens mais je crois que
ça n'ira pas forcément au bout et je ne
m'en plaindrai pas on verra on verra
pour l'instant il ya une niche centriste
à l'assemblée nationale et je pense que
la majorité par le nom de fin de
l'assemblée des députés sont très
divisés sur le sujet et donc elle peut
prospérer on
suivra sa merci beaucoup merci à ce
débat m